le procès des attentats du 13 novembre
continue à la barre aujourd'hui
notamment l'ancien chef de la bri qui
est intervenu au bataclan avant lui le
chef adjoint le chef adjointe de l'unité
de police de nuit la bac qui était entré
au bataclan en compagnie de son
chauffeur lui qui avait neutralisé l'un
des kamikazes il s'est exprimé également
à la barre on trouve tout de suite notre
reporter katia technique
bonjour katia vous suivez pour nous ce
procès historique compte rendu donc avec
vous de cette 10e journée d'audience
et où il ya en effet un c'est bien
l'ancien dirigeant de la br et
christophe molmy qui s'exprime en ce
moment un témoignage incroyable et bien
la berri c'est l'unité qui a mené
l'assaut contre les deux terroristes
restants ils sont intervenus à 22h20
cette nuit là au début de l'opération
ils ont commencé par évacuer les blessés
les les personnes encore vivantes puis à
23 heures ils ont formé deux colonnes
pour à les neutraliser les terroristes
et bien sûr libérer les otages otages
qui se trouvaient dont au balcon et au
niveau fête des loges ou de diverses
pièces alors en fait ce qu'il s'est
produit ceux qui sont arrivés en colonne
avec des opérateurs qui sont formels à
messine de compass qui ont des boucliers
un équipement très sophistiqué déboucler
par exemple qui résiste au feu des
kalachnikovs ils ont voulu ouvrir une
porte il y avait un otage derrière et à
23h15 et bien il ya eu un premier
contact avec les terroristes qui ont qui
ont donné des revendications comme par
exemple on vous tuer nos enfants en
syrie nous on tue les vôtres ici ces
négociations n'ont pas abouti alors le
préfet de police de l'époque michel
cadot a donné son autorisation et un
assaut a été enclenchée à zéro heure 18
la colonne à d'abord encaissé les tirs
et a exfiltré au fur et à mesure les
otages en progressant à l'est ces
colonnes ne recule pas elles sont
arrivées elles ont repoussé les deux
terroristes dans un escalier le premier
s'est fait exploser heureusement par
bonheur en tombant le souffle de
l'explosion s'est dirigé vers le haut et
donc il il ya eu finalement qu'un seul
blessé parmi les opérateurs aériens
parmi les otages donc évidemment le
bilan aurait pu être catastrophique si
le soufre avait été frontale et quant au
deuxième terroriste dans l'escalier il a
été abattu les otages a été encore dans
un local ils ont en dessous vente parce
qu'il y avait deux endroits en fait où
se trouvaient la plupart des otages ils
ont été libérés dans un second temps
avec un des mineurs qui s'étaient
allongés sur le terroriste mort pour les
protéger au maximum à 00h25 eh bien
c'était la fin de l'assaut on note qu
aucun otage n'a été tués durant l'assaut
et seul un opérateur a été blessé ce qui
est un véritable miracle merci beaucoup
katia technique et on continue de suivre
avec vous cette 10e journée 1 d'audience